Jetzt ist es bald wieder so weit.
Weihnachten steht vor der Tür –
das schönste Fest des Jahres.
Viele Deutsche mögen es besinnlich
und bringen sich auf den
Weihnachtsmärkten in Stimmung.
Aber die große Masse ist woanders:
Shoppen, bis es kracht.
Die Geschäfte rechnen in diesem Jahr
mit über 90 Milliarden Euro
Umsatz im Weihnachtsgeschäft,
3,9 Prozent mehr als im letzten Jahr.
Aber das Top-Weihnachtsgeschenk 2016 ist:
Geld – mehr als die Hälfte
aller Geschenke in Deutschland.
Auf dem zweiten Platz: Bücher, Literatur;
gefolgt von Lebensmitteln, Süßigkeiten.
Auf Platz vier: Kleidung.
Und dann natürlich: Spielzeug.
Gerade die Spielwarenindustrie macht
ihren Hauptumsatz zu Weihnachten.
Und dann gibt’s ja da noch
den Weihnachtsbaum.
Die kosten meistens ab 50 Euro aufwärts,
je nach Wuchs, Höhe und Aussehen.
Muss kräftige Tannen haben, damit
die Kugeln gut hängen, ne?
Und dann gerade Spitze.
Ja, und einfach saftig grün,
das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig.
Dieses Jahr sind die Bäume gut gewachsen,
sie hatten ausreichend Regen.
Die meisten Deutschen lassen ihren Baum
mehrere Wochen im Wohnzimmer stehen,
so lange, bis die Nadeln abfallen.
Rund 30 Millionen Bäume
werden dieses Jahr verkauft.
2015 lag die Durchschnittshöhe
bei 1,68 Meter.
Dieses Jahr dürfte er größer
ausfallen, der Hauptbaum!
Viele kaufen noch einen weiteren kleinen.
Der Trend geht zur Zweittanne
für den Balkon oder die Terrasse.
Ohne Baum kein gelungenes Fest.
Und der Braten muss
natürlich auch schmecken.
Auf den Weihnachtsmärkten essen die
Deutschen gern Spanferkel oder Bratwurst.
Die meisten kommen zum
Essen auf die Märkte.
Sie beginnen schon im November
und dauern bis Weihnachten.
Der Umsatz deutschlandweit:
zweieinhalb Milliarden Euro.
Aber zum ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag
muss es dann doch ein
besonderer Braten sein.
Nein, auf den Teller kommt auch
2016 selten Vegetarisches.
Auf Platz vier: Wild.
Auf Platz drei: Rinderbraten.
Und jeder sechste Deutsche isst Schwein.
Unangefochten auf Platz eins:
Gans oder Ente – jeder zweite Braten.
Und eine ganze Gans
kostet selten unter 50 Euro.
Wer noch etwas übrig hat,
spendet zu Weihnachten.
Das ist eine Spende für die Kinder aus
der Ukraine, die ohne Eltern sind.
So locker sitzt das Geld aber nicht.
Nur jeder fünfte Deutsche ist
dieses Jahr bereit,
etwas für einen guten Zweck zu geben.
Das war im letzten Jahr noch anders.
Da lag die Durchschnittsspende
bei 35 Euro.
Dieses Jahr nur bei 32 Euro.
Aber für einige gehört es zum
Weihnachtsfest einfach dazu.
Und natürlich die richtige Musik.
„Stille Nacht, heilige Nacht“ –
das mit Abstand
beliebteste Weihnachtslied.
Fast jeder Zweite singt es.
Wenn er denn nach dem Essen
und den ganzen Geschenken
dazu noch in der Lage ist.